hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled digital solutions to
alleviate nash clinical trial challenges
this webinar is a part of the fifth
annual drug discovery and development
virtual conference
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers
paul mccracken ph.d vice president
global head of medical imaging icon
debbie marshall program manager icon
and christina gonzalez project manager
pathology icon
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
paul debbie and christina you may now
begin your presentation
hi
thanks for joining us today my name is
paul mccracken i'm the vice president
and head of medical imaging at icon
i'm joined today by tina gonzalez and
debbie marshall
we're presenting on the digital
alternatives to alleviating nash
clinical trial challenges
briefly for those that aren't familiar
with icon we're a global
cro we provide outsourced drug and
device development services phase one
through phase four
where a large organization having
acquired pra health sciences last year
now some 38 000 employees
and you can see our distribution on this
map here leaders in fsp
full service phase two three clinical
research early phase late phase real
world evidence
central and specialty labs
we put together a nash initiative with
an icon pulling together our experience
and expertise you can find more
information at the link shown
today we're going to highlight some of
our nash expertise that we pulled
together within the organization
clinical research represented by debbie
marshall
tina gonzalez supporting some of the
digital pathology efforts we've found
and myself for medical imaging
one of the challenges we do see within
development in nash is the probability
of success
in general for metabolic diseases
there's a very low likelihood of
approval from phase one
to marketing some 15
when you move to phase two
it only improves to 25 percent
but specifically since 2016 there have
been 10 to 12 10 to 12 drug failures
uh to make it to approval during that
time despite significant investment in
that space there are high screen failure
rates some 40 to 60 percent and the fda
has asked that we target
uh late phase
disease within patient population so
identification of those patients and
showing a clinical benefit there is
absolutely critical
one of the things i like to do is frame
our drug development
challenges within
biomarkers is to look at this nice paper
that was published in 2014 by
astrazeneca they were having a
relatively low success rate in their
programs
and tried to come up with some
determinants for success within their
program and were able to do so and boil
it down to these sort of
this 5r framework right tissue target
safety patients commercial potential and
really describes a biomarker approach
towards drug development that has proven
and they published
the to improve the probability of
success of their programs and we take a
similar approach to development of nash
between imaging and labs you have
coverage of a number of biomarkers that
if used appropriately
can support and improve the probability
of success
of drug development representing medical
imaging
we have the leading
imaging group in nash within my
department
for medical imaging and icon we use
industry partners
in as well as nash crn radiologists for
comprehensive imaging solutions that
could substitute in part for invasive
liver biopsies we focus on mri pdf
and mr elastography i'll describe each
of those methodologies briefly today as
well as the processes around
those methods that allow us to deliver
the endpoints at the end of the trial
i'm sure most on the call are familiar
with disease progression
within nash where you see statosis and
fibrosis developing over time from an
imaging perspective mri pdf is able to
discern fatty tissue and that develops
very early on in the disease mr
elastography which looks at liver
stiffness
as a surrogate for fibrosis or
eventually cirrhosis
can be developed in in some of the later
stages and again we'll describe the
methodology
very briefly without getting into an mr
physics tutorial there are some methods
developed
called the dixon methods that basically
take advantage of the distinct
properties
between healthy tissue in the liver and
fatty tissue in the liver and by
manipulating a series of pull sequences
are able to actually
get images that can show you the fat
content and the water content within
liver tissue thereby being able to
measure steatosis
the different vendors g siemens and
phillips have developed sequences that
that do provide these maps of tissue
ge uses uh what's called a complex
method phillips uses what's called a
magnitude method and the liver lab by
siemens is a bit of a hybrid between the
two
this is an example of what some of those
maps look like
on the left you can see the complex the
right magnitude but but effectively get
you to the same endpoint which is an
overall distribution or map of of the
fat fraction
derived by mri pdf within the liver now
what's nice about these methodologies is
these are longitudinal they're
non-invasive um they're not subject to
the sampling bias that you see with
histopathology you're getting a 1 100
000th the volume of the liver in fact
you're able to capture very much the
entire volume of the liver and look at
different regions
as such
we do
uh require that we have certain cutoffs
when we're all patients and trials
10 is
used in some trials sometimes it's a
little bit higher a little bit lower
depends on the sponsor and the patient
population
they plan to pursue
but you want to make sure you have
enough of a dynamic range that when your
drug does have an impact on the patient
population or progression
that you're able to measure that in an
assessed civil
statistical manner
there's a lot of validation for these
methodologies these publications in fact
are aging out so there are a number of
publications that have come subsequent
to these that have again reinforced the
validity and value of mri pdf
as the leading method for measuring
statos is not basically in the liver
again have been compared versus mr
spectroscopy having compared versus
histopathology and shown to be uh
incredibly robust and
and uh very usable in the clinical trial
setting for assessment of these
pathologies this is just one example
recently shown by magical pharma that
has a number of assets
in the nash space showing a dose and
longitudinal dependent reduction in
relative fat fraction
in nash patients
as measured by mri pdf so it is being
used
by a number of biotech and pharma in
their clinical trials
in fact you can use imaging without
biopsy up through phase two to assess
changes in the liver and enroll patients
as supported by the fda
one of the things that we do
to make sure that
the assessment of mri pdf of fat
fraction has done appropriately and
accurately as we use
with our partners gene britain and her
team developed at calametrix a phantom
that can assess the uh
the scanner itself to g siemens and
phillips you place the phantom on the
left inside it has a number of fat
mimicking vials within it that range
across the spectrum of physiologic fat
fractions we can put those in there and
qualify a site to make sure they're
falling within specific ranges there's
also a phantom that we use that's placed
under patients in vivo in the scan
that can be used to qualify and quantify
that the rois that you're generating
that the values within the liver are in
fact within
an expected range and it's it's an
excellent qc proposition
for us in fact uh this is an example
the calimetric shares but this is a case
where from the imaging perspective the
the fat fraction map
derived by the scanner looks okay
there's nothing you know apparently
problematic about it but when you're
able to assess it with the vials of of
fat mimicking tissue underneath you're
able to see that in fact there was an
issue
from a technology perspective on this
particular patient scan
and the patient is able to be rescanned
will be able to detect this without the
phantom in place you would not have
known this and had erroneous data
potentially in your clinical trial
and just a few notes on the assessment
and enrichment
so
there's a few comments that we can make
here and a few that have been published
in this space
i won't summarize them all
but it's worth noting certainly mri pdf
it's it's known to be significantly more
accurate than other methods for
quantifying liver statosis and
absolutely should be used in baseline
and longitudinal assessments but there
are other methods that are ultrasound or
transient echo based
that can be used to enrich patient
populations so if you
have some basic you know questionnaire
and then want to screen some patients
with a a available and less expensive
tool you might use
something in that vein and then when you
start to bring patients into trials mri
pdfs is exquisite for that measurement
and just highlighting a few publications
um and i expect this number to reduce
over time
but certainly a relative reduction of 29
liver fat by mri pdf has been associated
and correlated well with histologic
response in nash
non-invasive quantitative precise and
reproducible mri pdf is emerging as a
useful biomarker assessment to treat
response in the setting of early phase
clinical trials in nash
um
scott reader and team
have spoken to this and published a
number of times
there's also another publication steiner
doll
the meta-analysis they did it i think it
was of six or seven clinical trials in
this space show that again um about a 30
relative decline in mri pdf is
associated with higher odds of a
histological response and nash
resolution you support the use of mri
pdf in non-invasive monitoring of
treatment response and early phase nash
clinical trials
and provide helpful data for sample size
estimation for histology based
assessments so again there's a wealth of
information out there to support these
methods in the space
next we have mr elastography for liver
stiffness surrogate fibrosis
i happen to have done my training with
dickemann at the mayo clinic
where my phd was actually studying the
elastography a technique i know well
and resounding is the company that has
been developed
to make the technology accessible
available reproducible
and from that you're able to effectively
put a small amplitude vibration into a
patient in this case it's a it's a
paddle
acoustic paddle underneath the patient
that then vibrates
using certain characteristics with an mr
you're able to actually look at the the
phase or the
the waves that propagate through that
tissue that's that mental image on the
bottom and from that
you can
convert those wave images to a stiffness
map and in fact interrogate the entirety
of the liver for stiffness
looking for fibrotic tissue
again it's important to have cutoffs in
patients such that they have evaluable
scans of valuable livers and sufficient
stiffness within the liver
to include them in trial and look for a
dynamic change in response to therapy or
progression
this map nicely illustrates again from i
think um
dickieman and his team publishing
that you can see in those middle panels
and the leftmost panels just by standard
mr you can see no difference between
those levers the middle panel
the same frequency vibration was entered
into the tissue and you can see the
change in wavelength or the difference
in wavelength across those three panels
from top to bottom
and on the right are the elastograms or
stiffness maps
showing
red being the most stiff approximately
eight kilopascals you can see the
increasing stiffness within those levers
and that's that kind of dynamic range
you're able to see
on that upper right panel there's a
correlation between
mr elastography and fibrotic stage again
every publication that's been out there
has reinforced the correlation between
those methodologies
with with very high accuracy and
reproducibility
and what's interesting to see is with
the development of the 2d mre methods
and now 3d mre methods that are becoming
more popular
you're able to not only look at liver
stiffness but then some of the
additional characteristics such as
damping ratios are providing incremental
information to that potentially looking
at the necro-inflammatory
congested and fibrotic processes of
chronic liver disease so it's a very
exciting space
um
with with significant
advancements coming
and again similar to pdf this is a
well-validated methodology for
assessment of fibrosis non-invasively
correlating to histopathology and in
myriad publications and and number of
publications have come subsequent to
this particular reference shown below
and again
these are being used in uh clinical
trials
the kiba for
mre of which i'm a participant
does have a consensus profile
stating a measured change antibiotic
stiffness of 19 or larger indicates a
true change in stiffness has occurred
with a 95 confidence again madrigal
and one of the recent publications have
shown
using mre and i think this is their
phase 2 trial results a change in
stiffness and depending on how you
segment the
patient population to responders
highly significant changes and
reductions and stiffness during the
trial duration
using mre elastography so again a superb
method for non-invasively assessing
changes within the liver and i spoke to
it earlier but i just wanted to
highlight with this image
from the journal of hepatology that
nicely shows that longitudinal
assessment so you're able to go back
from an imaging perspective to the same
region of interest over time and look
for that assessment and basically this
the patient acts as their own control so
you actually can do studies in a shorter
duration of time with fewer patients and
have in fact
higher reproducibility or lower
variability those two images pairs of
images in the bottom right
show the same patient at week 0 baseline
and week 24 showing the relative changes
in fat fraction and stiffness over time
again showing that really
strong capability for co-localization
which is certainly important now again
this reference i i i'm surely has been
updated but it points out that there is
a shift in the industry on that middle
column speaks to phase 2 proof of
concept trials that are longer than 48
weeks that have invasive liver biopsy
and you can see
the numbers of those trials are small
and incrementing very very slowly
that rightmost column in fact shows the
number of phase two proof of concept
trials that are shorter than 28 weeks in
duration
that incorporate
non-invasive liver measures of clinical
trials and you can see that's gone up
exponentially continues to go up
exponentially
and that's an important driver to say
you can make and the regulatory agencies
support this decisions about your trials
through phase two
without doing liver biopsy so that
allows you to
save biopsy for phase three and make
sure that you've demonstrated proof of
concept non-invasively in patient
populations to ensure that you have
chosen the right patients that you have
target engagement with your drug chosen
the right dose
and in fact see some level of efficacy
with safety so these are important
non-invasive characteristics and the
trend in the industry
so what can medical imaging do
hopefully i've been able to show you a
few pieces of that but we can improve
the success rates of clinical trials
you can use imaging to
identify patients and certainly to
stratify patients which is absolutely
important in these
trials especially in competition for
patients for these trials
we've shown that there is superb
correlation with histopathology
and i'll come back to that in just a
moment
these can be done longitudinally first
assessment of the liver it can be done
to reduce variability and i mentioned
sampling bias within
the liver
these are continuous sensitive measures
of change the current
scoring systems for for pathology and
nash are
right there they're scoring systems it's
f1 f2 f3 f4
whereas in fact with imaging you have a
continuous quantitative assessment and
therefore you have
an interesting approach to a statistical
difference between patients that's real
and meaningful
it is non-invasive that allows you to
get an early read on efficacy
potentially futility again decisions are
made within these trials that impact
lots of patients and financially and
being able to understand
how your drugs working early on is
absolutely critical
also one of the challenges they've seen
in clinical trials is the rates of
disease progression varies among
patients
patients of different backgrounds and
stages and imaging can help quantify the
trajectory again you don't want to do a
biopsy every 12 weeks or every six
months within the same patient but
imaging you could do in theory which
allow you to look at the trajectory of
different patients responders
non-responders etc
coming back to histopathology
one of the things that we've been able
to do icon is the only cro
that has imaging and labs under the same
roof and that has certainly some
benefits as those are the methodologies
used for development nash
but what it actually allowed us to do in
practice is
using the pax system for our imaging
database called mira
we were able to develop that system so
that it could be used for digital
digital histopathology
and tina is going to speak to you next
about how we've developed digital
histopathology
at icon and the value they're in
thanks again for your time and uh we'll
answer some questions after tina and
debbie speak
hi my name is tina gonzalez and i'm the
icon central laboratories pathology
project manager
as paul has mentioned i will be doing an
overview of digital pathology
we'll be discussing the benefits of
digital pathology in clinical trials as
well as the current infrastructure and
workflows
there are current challenges in nash
trials which are
that biopsy samples remain to be the
regulatory gold standard for efficacy
assessments however there's significant
variation in these assessments performed
by local and expert hepatopathologists
which creates a need for central experts
there is also the use of consensus
assessments which require extensive time
and shipping when using a glass slide
approach
this leads to an environmental impact as
well as a risk to slides by the
transport of samples to multiple
locations
additionally the time required to
provide a result to clinicians can be
large however there's a limited
screening window
additionally there is an absence of
currently available therapies to treat
nash and the time it takes to complete a
nash study
there are some benefits
and that would
help with digital pathology
with digital pathology there's no
shipping of glass slides to expert
hepatopathologists
instead a digital image it is made
available via our portal mira
with this shipping between facilities is
not required and shipping materials as
well as courier expenses would only be
needed for shipments from the site to
icon
there is also improved turnaround time
from specimen receipt to the report of
results and the average turnaround time
for a multi-hyped pathologist workflow
is halved
the digital images provide an option of
an automated analysis via ai
technologies
and there's also a reduced cost risk of
loss and environmental impact when using
digital pathology
additionally
digital pathology can help enable
creation of customizable lean efficient
and timely workflows such as those
listed here below
some examples would be a single
pathologist's view or a
multi-pathologist workflow
additionally there are benefits of
digital pathology to our expert
hepatopathologists
our pathologists could be located
anywhere in the world but all work from
the same image
the digital images would enable expert
hepatopathologists to discuss examples
in real time
and it increases their ability for
harmonization throughout the duration of
the study
some examples of this would be
facilitating regular calibration calls
to optimize accuracy and avoid drift
over time
and it also allows the pathologist to
discuss any contentious cases
some additional benefits of the digital
tools for the pathologist are that all
images are ready readily available
as are the list dependent cases
we can also accommodate valuable input
from our key opinion leaders and
implement changes in
some examples would be customizable
ecrfs customizable case notification
emails as well as the ability to view
all images for a case even if a
cancellation occurs on the first set of
slides
next we'll move on to digital pathology
infrastructure and workflow
at icom we currently use a program
called mira which is linked to the leica
at2 as well as the at2dx
from there we're able to scan the whole
slide images and which allows the
pathologist to review them via mira
an example of how mira works
is that the pathologists would log in
and this is how this main screen looks
to a pathologist
they could then select the sponsor
protocol
queue as well as the code the
identified code
and the corresponding barcode
if you'll note here there is a watermark
that appears on when the slides are
scanned on the at2dx
and if the images are viewed on a
non-medical grade monitor
from there the combination of the at2dx
and medical grade monitor would satisfy
the fda requirements if a primary
diagnosis is required
however as we all know primary diagnoses
are not provided by a central lab so
presence of the watermark would be
acceptable
next when
logging into mira
and the
case is selected
the
image as well as the case report form
will appear to the pathologist
at first all of the
questions would be noted in red
and when completed by the pathologist
they would move to green
once all questions have been completed
the complete form button will then
appear and allow each pathologist to
sign off on their read
from there you can see that the
[Music]
workflow
is relatively similar to what you may
expect from sample receipt but then it
changes to accommodate digital pathology
we currently can receive samples as
tissue fresh tissue blocks on stained
slides or even stained slides
as needed we can stain the samples
then digitally image them from there the
automatic images
will transfer to mira
where our laboratory team can complete
an image qc
and then automatically assigned
each case to a pathologist
depending on how you'd like your read to
be done
that we could do a primary review
as read by individual pathologists
if an agreement the case would be
released to the site however if they're
in disagreement the case would
automatically move to a consensus queue
if at consensus the pathologist can
agree the results will be immediately
reported out to the site
however if they disagree it would go to
an adjudication queue for a read by a
third pathologist
from there the results would be
finalized and reported out to sites
in summary
we've discussed the current challenges
and nash trials such as glass slides
that must be created and shipped which
risk damage to sides and impacts the
environment
there's a variation in assessments
performed by local and expert
hepatopathologists
there's limited screen screening windows
but longer timelines needed to provide
results
and the absence of currently available
therapies in the time it takes to
complete a study
there are benefits to digital pathology
such as no shipping of glass slides
which leads to reduced cost
reduced risk of loss damage as well as
environmental impact
and it improves turnaround times from
specimen receipt to reporting of results
there are additionally benefits to the
pathologist when using digital pathology
and that is that the digital images
allow experts to be anywhere in the
world but all work from the same image
and we can easily arrange calibration or
consensus meetings to help optimize
accuracy and reduce the risk of drift
over time
finally we've discussed the digital
pathology infrastructure and workflows
where icon utilizes mira and image scope
to collect manage and host digital image
data
and also enable the creation of
customizable lean workflows that address
the needs of protocol and expert
hepatopathologists
now if there's any questions we can go
over those at the end and now i'll be
moving on
to
debbie marshall a program manager
of clinical operations thank you
hi
my name is debbie marshall like tina
mentioned i am a program manager here at
icon in the clint ops area you might
wonder why i'm actually participating in
this presentation since i'm not talking
about digital capabilities
the point is is that all these amazing
amazing technologies that paul and tina
spoke about won't matter unless we find
the right sites as well ensure that they
understand the requirements to be in a
nash study
over the next few slides i'll explain
how we in operations support our imaging
and lab partners in these complex nash
trials
so whenever i give presentations on
managing nash trials i typically start
with the challenges that they provide
and how icon can alleviate these
challenges for the sites and the
sponsors
today i'm just going to speak on this
section though
imaging and liver biopsy challenges
requiring these procedures at this time
in nash trials will limit site and
country selection and let me caveat this
by saying if we are dealing with the
site that has participated in nash
trials previously worked with icon
imaging or labs that's great these
challenges risks are removed
however oftentimes due to the
competition in the nash space
we are expanding the site identification
net to bring up new sites who have nash
nafld patients
and are interested in getting involved
instead of just the standard hepatology
gi sites that we used to go to back in
the day for nash trials we are now
working with endocrine family practice
internist emergency medicine and on and
on
these are the sites that in the
beginning of their nash trial experience
might not be aware of what is all
required or have immediate access to
like the mri pdf mre or biopsy
so what my team will do then is we will
do a thorough feasibility at the very
beginning to determine what capabilities
the sites do have
now if they are interested in nash and
do have the patient population
but do not have the capabilities we'll
do an extra step by reaching out to the
site to help them liaise with imaging or
biopsy vendors
so once we have confirmed our
feasibility and completed the
questionnaires and all that's done
then we move forward to psv's right so
pre-site selection
um now at the time of outreach for
getting these psps scheduled i will also
attach some checklists because even
though
the feasibility questionnaire was filled
out and all the boxes are checked yes
yes yes we have this i just want to make
sure that they truly understand
what they were checking yes to
so one of these first checklists i
provide is the mri pdf checklist
now
you could tell by reading this that
um it's got techn you know um technical
language so to say so
a ordinary person on the site staff
would read this and not really
understand it which is the goal we
really want them to be handing this over
to the imaging group to check it and
make sure that they do have these
um
requirements
so you can see here too this one does a
scanner have the following
manufacturer's liver application for ge
it's ideal iq for philips it's index and
quant for siemens it's liver lab if the
site does answer no or an a to all of
these doesn't necessarily mean they'll
be out of the study but it means that it
will require an intervention from icon
imaging to maybe help them through this
process or find some and find another
sequence that works okay now the good
thing about this is we give icon imaging
a head start right we so they can
prioritize this site
the next checklist we provide is the mre
checklist
so
you know mre you either have it or you
don't right so because there's an
application that comes from resounding
so this this one shouldn't be that hard
however i've had sites accidentally
um you know check off mre but they
really had mr inter enterography not
elastography so they are two completely
different things so this is just another
assurance on my side that yes they know
what we're talking about we know we're
talking about electrography and they
have that application
and finally it's the liver biopsy
checklist so this is really to ensure
that the site has thought about this
requirement and have a plan in place to
ensure scheduling performing and
receiving samples will not be an issue
in the trial
okay so now after we've completed our
psv's or you could call them
qualification visits or our um
site selection visits or whatever you
want to call them um
these sites now are formally selected
right so now they're ready to move
forward with study startup contracting
irb submissions and all that kind of
stuff
so as soon as we have a site that is
formally selected
we will send out an email stating you
know congratulations you have been
selected for the study in that email i
will immediately introduce icon imaging
so they can start working on this
phantom qualification okay because
this is an important step you want to
make sure this phantom qualification is
done well in advance of sib inactivation
because without this
you can't move forward with the study
right so all these other tasks are would
be a mute point right so um you know we
get this going very early if there is a
problem with phantom qualification
that's going to again require icon
imaging intervention and perhaps clinops
you know because we could then go out
and look for any other sites that we
have local to this
site that maybe can help which is help
the site participate in the study but
again it's you know we're working
together to make sure this site can get
activated
and then finally after sites are up and
running and participating in the study
the clinical team must continue their
collaboration with imogene and labs
so you could see here we have a standard
screening window for a nash trial
it's eight weeks right seems like a long
time but there are a lot of procedures
that need to happen in here and most
often they are sequential
right so for example we start out with
med history con meds vitals ekg labs
maybe fibroscan right there in the
clinic okay
um usually takes a few days to get those
labs back
so maybe depending on what they are
three to five days i would say
after you have confirmation that these
eligibility procedures have been um met
then you move forward to mri pdf and mre
okay but not until these are met do you
want to move forward there's no point in
performing an mre if you've got a
platelet of 80 right so then you make
sure that these are performed and that
they're um sent in and then icon imaging
team can analyze them and provide
results
now i give this about
13 days um it doesn't take that long
from imaging side but the site has to
perform and send them in
right
so then after this is all done you move
forward to liver biopsy because
you know oftentimes now i will see in
protocols that there is a cut off
requirement in the eligibility criteria
for pdf and mre
so let's say your pdf is two percent
chances are they're not going to be a
patient qualified to move forward to
biopsy
so anyway we now we go to biopsy biopsy
does take the longest
right because you've got to perform it
you've got to prepare the slides or the
you know the block or the tissue then
they've got to send it in and then it's
got to come to icon labs
to be processed and analyzed on our end
so the point of this is is there is a
set length of time for all of these
procedures to happen and it takes strong
teamwork between the sites and clinical
and imaging and labs to make all of this
work
and in summary by us all collaborating
we get
a quicker startup period
we don't exceed screening window
expectations because we know where the
patient is within that window and we
make sure the sequential procedures are
occurring on time
and we meet the contractual timeline set
forth by the con the contract and the
client
and that's it
so
now we will open up to some questions
thank you again paul debbie and
christina for your time today and your
important research before we go i'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until february twenty twenty
four
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye